we've been reporting today about
desperate parents stealing baby formula
OS statistics suggesting highest food
price prices
on record is that acceptable in a
country as rich as the UK but I I know
the cost of living is the number one
challenge facing British families at the
moment that's why my number one priority
out of my five priorities is to half
inflation to ease those burdens on the
cost of living one of the most important
things we are doing to help families
with a cost of living is helping with
energy bills I made a decision to tax
the windfall profits of energy companies
last year we're using that money to help
pay for People's Energy bills and right
now about half of the typical
household's energy bill 1500 pounds is
being paid by the government that should
give people a sense that we are on their
side we are trying to help with this
with food in particular which of course
is something we want to help with we've
got to recognize right now there are
challenges across Europe inflation rates
in most European countries similar to
ours we have particular support for
young families something called Healthy
Start vouchers which provide money to
young young families with the cost of
fresh food but also the household
support fund is a billion pounds and
we've given to local councils that
families can go and talk to their
Council about to get that extra support
that specific there to help them on top
of all the things we're doing as I said
most importantly helping with energy
bills by taxing when for profits of
energy companies